Hasegawa morose - PewDiePie welcome back
to among the sleep know what that was
tickling your tits
so we've been waiting for this game for
over a year now
I'm so [ __ ] pumped to actually play
it it's a horror game where you play as
a baby how [ __ ] cool is that so we
already got a little snip letter O with
what it's gonna be like and it seems
pretty awesome I'm definitely excited
for more so let's keep playing
so I don't know if you will start from
the same point uh or if that what we saw
before it was just like a dam or
whatever I think what we played through
was a demo Oh press any key I'm sorry so
I hope this will be new for us
whatever happened yep it seems new
alright there is an option to play with
the oculus rift by the way I could not
even if I tried I couldn't a got what
the [ __ ] is happening
this baby's tripping out on drugs or
some weird [ __ ] man
did you finish your drink on o or that
careful shut up don't tell me what to do
mommy just has to make sure that the
cake is perfect okay hey whatever it
better be let me see her ball the blue
needs to be over here and all the red
needs tick goddamn it's not perfect
your listen to me red that's right
[ __ ] red a [ __ ] red [ __ ] just like
my note don't speak bad at my mama
why isn't you adorable and your tiny
footed pajamas it's Gucci so it better
be good now let's see here happy
birthday sweetie
like the art style Wow
two years today yep oops I think I know
a little someone who's ready for some
cake chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga cheese
for the tunnel she's sorry i
shouldn't've it look at what why did she
seem so depressed right back that booty
though
alright well back to my collecting all
right you see red come on red come on
ah what what's going on oh god it's not
perfect is it nothing will ever be
perfect well I got cake and I got math I
don't understand
Oh Oh Lois I don't like to be okay
away from mom is that it wonder what it
is why don't we go upstairs and find out
why not here what kind of present is
this oh my how much cake did you have
Wow building my confidence at a low wage
huh great this is a really awkward angle
I can see your nose hair oh god oh god
oh god oh no yeah too much cake uh
krillbite studio ah this is pretty oh
god no what is going on over there I
don't like that at all
percents what are they going to present
I can't possibly imagine what they're
going to present oh ok again I get a
ball I've come for you lady [ __ ] so the
demo what you had to do was save your
teddy and Teddy was like an actual
character I thought that was pretty
awesome and I was saying before was that
I can't play without clothes even if I
want you I might do one episode we are
full game it's I'll throw up maybe it's
a new toy better better be a [ __ ]
sweet ass transformer oh it's daddy
okay sweetie be a dear and play for a
bit mommy will be right back now don't
bring teddy why is she putting me the
hell is happening here oh god okay I'm
in prison great now what oh god Teddy
Teddy you gotta help me
he walks a funky I got a ball I got a
ball ball ball girl and it's my hat girl
use left control to crawl all right we
better get out of here I'm a lot faster
on my yeah it says even there Thank You
game and I'm Assassin's Creed baby
edition come on you can do it climb why
the [ __ ] did I do that
come on get your [ __ ] together man now
you're just stuck but the moment feels
kind of real like you can't just do
whatever the Frick you want again I
already did this what's this third tip
as a pillow there you want jump for some
reason there we go
conveniently placed pillow score I'm
bringing you with me hello you're my
favorite alright we need to grab at bad
Teddy I've seen the door hmm
oh yeah you use the joys of stairs
remember now get away get away you get
away you get away now
but away come on get in pillow
okay all right you know what [ __ ] it
Gandalf what do you do it hi Pat you
know what great seeing you was that all
I needed I thought it was gonna get
Teddy again I'll just dis you and me
baby
we need to find a way out of here MA we
need more cake all right don't worry I
got this
okay it's too far it never had a problem
opening a door before I better crawl or
maybe it's just like a wiki [ __ ] around
oh there you are
hey man you found me yeah Teddy my name
is Teddy nice to meet you hey [ __ ]
your name
um I don't know if I should tell him
it's not much of a talker yuning my eyes
I was pouts let's play a game all right
why do you want to play it in no I'll
hide the pink elephant while you're not
looking oh he's like playfully so cute
all right hide him then what you gonna
do about that ain't nobody take candle
for me don't why Kenya turn around
did we skate get out of your eyes I'm so
pissed don't be scared get it
all right I'm covering them escape
what the [ __ ] there you can look now
what it's right there it's right there
what do you think oh you think I'm
stupid don't you
my god I've never been so insulted in my
entire life found it Jesus I'm [ __ ]
40 pi god there's a don't worry about
Kenneth is this patronizing eyes WoW is
that a music box doesn't work I don't
know I'm not allowed to trust test it
touch whatever don't isn't doing it
come here all right mom says you can't
touch that only a kid okay you know what
I'll do it cuz I know you'll mess it up
otherwise all right let me just set a
nice melody I got my tricks okay all
right here we go there we go
how do i how do I do it that it oh yeah
all right what do you want what do you
want what do you want what do you want
what do you want come on tell me I'm
doing my little dance for you here
don't don't don't treat scandal get out
I'm had pets I'm that it's okay I'm with
you what's this my God he's so negative
right what do you want five thirsty
animals upon a dry dry hill it's
Japanese we could use a drink they sang
and started to drill unless we reach
water with our newly dug well I think
we'll have to bid each other fairly well
ha ha ha Swedish letter another
Norwegian I don't know if they have that
letter in Norway actually I guess so or
they just love Sweden I mean every one
of Sweden let's be honest does it run
how do you start it well I'll tell you
it's very advanced mechanic animism hey
that's kind of spy come on man don't be
a jerk and scandal spot don't worry dad
you can sit there an exam oh god what's
that atrocity all right
I'll explain to you try to keep up you
click this button round and round and
round so this is the horror game thank
you carry me on your back I want to show
you something but but I can't have don't
be jealous ok we made someplace very
dark how about your clothes it look at
that and all right well I don't know
what you want to do what about there
all right fine you know what fine Durga
way not away now
ah superstring yeah a guy's gonna be
spooky first you're not darker shut the
doors completely hello I don't like this
all right
this will do nicely I hope there are no
monsters in here um if you ever feel
scared in a dark place like this you can
hug me tightly you might feel a little
bit safer F to hug Teddy there I am
hugging you
you just wanted me to hug you alone in
the closet didn't yet Oh God I'm all
it's all got go go [ __ ] Shambo I know
what I'm doing okay
I like it it's creepy man whoa
what is going on here you can see the
imagination of and stuff it's what takes
over and that's God's smoking man did
you leave
Santoshi something's coming
now guide are we entering another world
oh here you are
Oh doing in the closet I'm nothing Teddy
told me today with your new friend
hello mr. bear nice to meet you how are
you today his name is Teddy dammit
you've got to stop hiding from mommy I
hope you had a good birthday hon mommy
would be very sad if you didn't and now
it's time for bed already if you go to
sleep now you can wake up early tomorrow
and play with your friend
all ah
but kisses man playing that with the
akka lives would be so weird and girl
they're sleeping now all over the world
and they're waiting just for you we
shouldn't keep them good night hon bye
rich man I guess up
mm-hmm-hmm I figured I'd close my eyes
but no it does it for me it's pretty
cool so far I like it
oh that's nighttime I think this is what
reminds me oh what the devil would like
no God I'm pretty tired
try not y'all like alright yep we play
this in the demo I think not sure God
Teddy now that is [ __ ] creepy man ohh
Oh daddy
Oh what okay this is creepy
what ow how the how the physics even
work
gaga Go Go [ __ ] Daniel get out your
chemic with me Daniel we wait to be
unbeatable
okay don't give me that smirky look
don't I said don't
I love you but it's not gonna work I'm
gonna tell you now okay I'll put you
there don't worry I'll put you there
what does it sound like the parents are
having sex
oh that's what the horror is all about I
got it Oh God hello no good I remember
this
Ted is in here
it's log now what the Frank don't tell
me what to do why thank you you're
welcome
not right we need to find your mother
okay well what about Gandalf no he walks
oh okay
Oh God what okay you know what vault you
go first
yes sergeant pills make sure it's safe
it's safe
all right thanks mol guy crawl faster
down oh god what the [ __ ]
know what might be listening what might
be listening what is it what does that
even mean it
oh god I remember this I remember all of
it and I don't like it not one big eye
oh god oh god oh god I didn't remember
that [ __ ] but it's some weird Japanese
porn again yeah damn my mom's a pervert
get damn it Oh God
someone looting the fridge these apples
are gigantic mind cod is bananas Jesus
all right so I'm not even gonna bother I
know what I have to do so I might as
well just do it cuz it doesn't look like
much has changed and that I want to
spend too much time doing stuff I
already know how to do alright let me go
hello Oh jack Oh God that actually
scared me huh that was creepy man oh god
I'm so bad I'm the next because oh man
what kind of writing is that like okay
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hello all right I'm hugging you Teddy
you're not oh I have to her you keep
hugging him okay let's dorable by the
way Oh God
oh [ __ ] nothing what's with the Japanese
Kanji like it is that what it is and if
so why that this game was no region
maybe she's married to Japanese man yes
that would make sense alright we need to
climb here and then we need to climb
here and then I think we can no there
you go it's dangerous but I'm a baby I
was almost dead man oh yeah
mom mom that was a monster you gotta
save me mom
Nani okay okay alright I'm hiding
what are you doing here this is my
hiding spot go find your own God
alright you tell me what you see hello
is that you oh god I can hear her
what is going on ma'am uh-oh oh god is
that [ __ ] thing again aah
hello I'm innocent okay check it get out
of my way my mom I'm ready to bring this
banana in case something happens
nothing's happening on my banana watch
okay baby
right now oh my [ __ ] god you made me
drop my banana not okay so that's where
the demo ended I think
can't believe I took what 20 minutes
last time Jesus no way it didn't end
here actually I remember now
you walk into this [ __ ] wonder what is
this
I don't know Teddy I don't know I think
we're going into another diamond
dimension and a neck mixes vortex can
you see your reflection
am I in a mirror
yeah I'm in a mirror it's her but it it
seems more like a memory why looks
pretty - I like the colors now I have an
inventory of a pendant thank you that's
our mom's necklace isn't it
Oh God Shrek that's where their demo
ended I think all right well now I
haven't played at least that's you all
right uh-oh
so he can live here it's arty anywhere I
don't know I'm trying to spell letters
okay and whatever come here
that's a good little teddy I love you
teddy I love everyone except Gandalf no
I'm just kidding I love that [ __ ] I'm
climbing over this is seriously Mirror's
Edge what's that doing here I don't know
that is weird man what does that do it
this is in my memory is his name I'm
going inside my memories
I got it yeah guy go go
uh is there someone there I was a lad up
to the window maybe I can get the door
open from the inside all right I didn't
know this was Mission Impossible but I
guess you'll have to do I'm I'm pretty
much tall enough this house is pretty
small okay Wow gonna have to end the
first episode there it's pretty awesome
so far and I hope you're enjoying it as
much as I am go ahead and leave a like
right now and very much appreciate it
and I will see you tomorrow in the next
episode unless I upload another video
today but who knows maybe a awesome res
this one's for you